NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
こんにちは、UITのテオです。ユーザーインターフェースとテクノロジーを愛する開発者のためのPodcast「UIT INSIDE」、今回もやっていきたいと思います。今回は浜田さんと喜楽さんと一緒に、2026年の Google I/O の現地から報告させていただきたいと思います。よろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
よろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
では早速ですが、メンバーの自己紹介から入りたいなと思ったんですけど、浜田さんは前も何回か Google I/O 関連でこの Podcast に出ていただいたんですけど、もう一回ご紹介をお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
今 LY で Web ディビジョンのリードを担当している浜田です。同時に Yahoo! トップページの技術 Tech リードもしています。よろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
喜楽さんは今日で初めての出演、自己紹介をお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku
LINE ヤフーの喜楽といいます。今は Yahoo! ニュースのエンジニアリングマネージャーをしています。よろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Google I/O なんですけど、2026 年も去年と同じ、いつも同じ場所ですよね。会場はショアラインアンフィシアターっていう場所なんですけど、Google の本社からちょっとだけ離れた大自然の中のシアターで開催されました。流れとしてなんですけど、2 日あって、1 日目がキーノートっていう Google の新機能とか一番推しの新しいフィーチャーとかが紹介されるイベントがあって、そのキーノートの後がデベロッパーキーノートがあって、そこで開発者向けの新しい Google さんが作った機能だったり開発者ツールだったりの紹介がありました。その後は同じ敷地内にいろんなブースとかがあったりして、そのブースを回ると各テーマ、AI と Android と Web のテーマに分かれたセッションとか体験できるブースとかがあったりして、そこを回りながら今回 LINE ヤフーから 3 人で参加しました。すごいいい天気なのと、来たことある人は分かると思うんですけど、すごくカラッとした空気で天気がいいので、日に焼ける体験をしながら見るんですけど、今回も暑かったんですが、やっぱり空気がすごく気持ちよくて、お祭りの感じというか、フェスを体験しているような、そんな空気の中で新技術を聞けるというようなイベントになっています。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
美味しいご飯も Google さんにいただいて、3 食 Google さんに出していただいてというところで、気候も温かいですし、人もやっぱりすごくパワフルで熱量ある方が自分たちの信じている技術を伝えたいというところはひしひしと伝わってきましたね。やっぱりフェスみたいな空間が、いつもと違ってもうちょっと積極的になっていろんな人に声かけやすいんですよね。Google の開発者であったり、他の Web フロントエンドの開発者であったり、それともまた全然違う分野で活躍してる人と会話する機会がいっぱいある、そういうネットワーキングイベントとしてもすごい活躍できたなって思います。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
実際キーノートとか Google I/O でどういう新しい機能とかどういう新しいものが紹介されたかというと、一番メインのキーノートで今回主に自分が考えた中で 3 つの新しいものが紹介されたと思います。1 個目が Gemini のモデルファミリーの新しい Flash モデルですね。今まで 3.1 のバージョンだったんですけど、それが 3.5 になって性能がだいぶ上がった上で、Flash なのですごい流動的に答えを出してくれるモデルになりますね。今の中だとやっぱり高速化したっていうところが一番大きくて、これまで以上に性能がいいのに、これまで以上に早いっていうところが一つ時代を新しくしたなという感じを受けました。モデルの速さが TPS で測られることが多くて、トークンパーセカンド、秒速のトークン数なんですけど、この Flash っていうモデルは 200 以上の TPS で、3.1 のバージョンの Pro とほぼ同じクオリティのものを提供するので、かなりインパクト強そうなモデルだなと思いました。コストももちろん Pro よりだいぶ低くて、前の世代のモデルより速いスピードで優れたアウトプットが提供できるのはすごいなって思いました。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
大きいインパクトありそう。今回 Pro のモデルが紹介されなかったことはちょっとびっくりしましたね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Flash モデルしかなくて、Flash モデルは即日自分の Gemini アプリにも入ったりとかして、すぐに動かせる形になっているので、3.5 の Pro がいつ来るかみたいなアナウンスもなかったですし、そこはどういう性能かっていうのもまだまだ見えてこない部分かなと思ってます。近いうちにみたいなこと言ってましたね。
同じ Gemini なんですけど、モデルの方じゃなくてアプリの方のアナウンスメントもちょっとあって、これは結構面白いアナウンスだと思ったんですけど、Spark っていう新しいエージェントが年内、今年の夏までにリリースされるっていう話があったんですけど、多分皆さんが Claude Code のような最近話題のエージェントを多分きっと回してる人もいると思うんですけど、Google さんはそれをプロダクト化して本当に一般的なユーザーにも届けるようなものがこの Spark っていうエージェントになります。これ確かまず何のものかというと、これはエージェントなので Gemini アプリから何かのタスクとかやりたいこととかをそのエージェントに投げたら、その後スマホとかパソコンを閉じてもそのエージェントが自律的に仕事を進めてゴールまで持っていくというようなプロダクトになります。Google はすごいたくさんのアセットを持っているので Gmail だったり Docs だったり、それこそ仕事のすべてをそこで完結できるようなアセットを持っているので、これが自律的に動いて仕事をこなしてくれるっていう風に考えると、かなり大きなインパクトあるのかな。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
キーノートは去年もちょっとこれについて話してたんですけど、昔は結構新しい開発者向けの機能や API がメインだったんですけど、最近になってほとんど AI の話になってて、今年もそうなってたんですよね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
3 個目の大きいアナウンスも AI 関連のものだったんですけど、これは Gemini ではなくて検索、Google Search の中の新しい機能だったんですけど、そこは大きく 2 つに分けると 1 個目が Generative UI のところですね。Generative UI というとどんなものか、なかなか想像しにくいと思うんですけど、今検索をすると、おそらく AI Overview が開いて、ある程度の検索結果をまとめて表示してくれると思います。Generative UI というのは、そういった AI が生成した答えというものをよりリッチな表現にして表現する新しい UI のことです。これは Generative UI という英語であると言うのですが、これはコードをその場で自動生成してしまって、その中で表示するような HTML だったり、インタラクティブの少しリッチなアプリケーションだったりを検索結果の中に表示してしまって、より深い理解だったりとか、わかりやすい表現が Generative UI の中でできるというような機能になっています。すごい面白くて、実際にコードが出てくるんですよね。エンジニアが書いたみたいにコードがバババッと画面に表示されて、その後 UI が出てくるような少し面白い仕掛けになっていて、初めて見る人はびっくりするんじゃないかなと思いました。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
検索からバイブコーディングしているというのはかなりびっくりして、我々も実際見てきたんですけど、週末旅行行きたいとなった時に、旅行を計画するためのウェブサイトが Google の検索からできてしまうというところはなかなか、Google プロダクトのつながりとしても、単に検索、何かを検索するというよりかは、何かを作るという方向に動いていたのは良かったかなと思います。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
フロントエンドエンジニアのアナウンスを見るとちょっと 2 つの異なった気持ちになるんですけど、1 個目はすごいこれはすごい便利そうだなっていう感想なんですけど、もうちょっとしばらく考えるとゴクッてなって、我々の仕事は今後どうなるんだっていう感想もありますね。実際にネットでもそういう反応が結構あったりしてて、要するに検索結果の初期画面でウェブサイトを作らなくて良いような情報が作られて出てしまうということになるので、全てが AI の中で取り込まれていくような、そんなプロダクトに成長するとなってしまうんじゃないかなと、ちょっと不安も半分ありますね。
その反応としてブログ記事が早速いろいろと出てて、例えば海外のジャーナリストが「Google は Web と戦争する気だ」みたいな記事を出したりしてて、あと日本でも似たような声が上がったりしましたね。mizchi さんとかも懸念のブログ記事を出してたりして、それは面白く拝読させていただいたんですけど。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
今回に関連するもう一個のちょっと炎上するアナウンスがあったんですけど、それは実際にキーノートじゃなくてキーノートの翌日にアナウンスされた、広告に関連するアナウンスですね。これは AI モードが生成するユーザーのクエリに対する答えに今後広告を入れるっていう発表でしたね。それでエージェントの答えてくることを信頼できなくなるかとか、そういう批判の声はやっぱりちょっとありましたね。実は私たちもそうなんですけど、検索の広告で売り上げを出しているので、おそらくここはかなり皆さんシビアに考えているところなのかなと想像しています。自分も注目していたところでは AI モードが最初の接点として切り替わってしまうんじゃないかなと思ったんですけど、今回はその発表はなかったです。検索結果はそのまま以前のものでというのは、サイトの接点は AI Overview で切り替わるということなんですけど、次のステップとしては切り替わる前に一旦その AI モードの中に広告を入れる、検索広告をそこの中で成長させるという方向に舵を切っていっているのかなと思っています。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
業界が変わりそうですね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
いろいろ今動いていて面白い部分でもあり、またちょっと怖いところでもあって、現地 Googler の方と話しても、なんか Google 自体もこの新しい世界の正解がわからないといった声が多くて、今みんなでオープンな Web を作りましょうという発言もあったので、そこはまさにそうだなと思いました。こういう時代になったからこそ、連携して今後も持続可能な Web を築くことしかないなって思いました。エコシステムがこれからまた大きく変わっていくと思うので、一緒に成長できる未来を描いていけるように、私たちも食いついていかないといけないなと思っています。
そこが Google のプロダクトに関する発表だったんですけど、Google I/O は結構プラットフォームに関する発表が多いので、我々フロントエンドエンジニアは Web に関連する発表が一番興味があるんですけど、それについてちょっと話していきたいなと思いました。デベロッパーキーノートで結構 vibe coding が今年のテーマになってたんですけど、いくつかの発表があったんですね。例えば Antigravity という新しいエージェントなんですけど、新しくないのか、前から Antigravity のエディターがあったと思うんですけども、そこの辺り書かない手を入れられてきたかなと思っていて。やっぱりこれまで vibe coding のところは Codex が強いっていう中で、あんまり存在感がなかったってところが正直なところだと思うんですけど、どのセッションを見ても最初に Antigravity が出てきてそれを使って何かするみたいなデモが行われてるってところで、力の入れようはすごかったですね。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
そうですね、なんか IDE もあって CLI も一緒に発表されて、SDK もできるみたいな形で、SDK ちょっと気になりますよね。自分のプロダクトの中でエージェントをユーザーに使わせるみたいなこともできるので、これも面白いですね。なんか ADK SDK で作ったら Google Cloud の VM で動くみたいな話があったので、それもかなり便利そう。すごく強い機能を割と簡単に手に入りそうだなと思いました。Google はこれまで開発環境という意味では少し一歩遅れをとってきていたんですけど、VS Code だったりとか他の Web 系のエンジニアが使うようなエディターだったりエージェントっていうのは今別のところにある気がしていて、そこの統合開発環境っていうのを今回 Antigravity でガッとシェアを取っていきたいのかなっていうのをすごく感じました。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
なるほど。Claude Code とかが出されたことに対して、Gemini CLI とかも出されたじゃないですか。でも今回 Antigravity の CLI も増えて。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku
その 2 つの信頼の関係がどうなるかとかもちょっと気になりますね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Antigravity の方がよりリッチなサポート範囲が大きくて、Gemini の方はよりジェネレイティブというか一般的なもの、ジェネラルなものなのかなと思ってます。
同じ vibe coding に関連するものなんですけど、もうちょっと多分フロントエンド開発分野に特化したものなんですけど、個人的に今回の I/O で一番これすごいいいなって思ったところが Modern Web Guidance というものなんですけど、これはエージェントが使うスキルになりました。最近エージェントに新しいスキルとか新しい何かを教えたいときは、スキルっていうディレクトリの配下に Markdown とか色々置いて、エージェントが Markdown のディスクリプションに一致する作業をする前にそのスキルを読み込んで、その読み込んだスキルを元にタスクを行うっていう流れのものが最近増えてるんですけど、Google さんはこの Modern Web Guidance っていうものをスキルとして公開しました。そのスキルの目的は何かというと、モデルがトレーニングされるとき、トレーニングに使われるデータがだいたい最新のデータじゃなくて、本当に大規模な LLM になるので、トレーニングも数ヶ月かかるケースがあるので、最新でも数ヶ月前のデータになることが多いです。そうすると、モデルが理解している世界が、今の世界ではなくて数ヶ月前の世界になってしまうんですよね。特に最近 Web プラットフォームにすごい新しい API が増えたりしてて、エージェントにその新しい API がまだわからないとか、トレーニングデータであんまり新しいものなので効率的に使われてなかったとか、今もうちょっと効率いい方法があるのに古いやり方でやってたみたいな問題が結構あったらしくて、Chrome チームがせっかくいっぱい新しい API 作ってるのに、Claude Code とかそういったエージェントがそれを使ってくれないという課題を抱えていた上で、今回の Modern Web Guidance というスキルを作ったんですね。このスキルは、これもまだいいなと思ったんですけど、これは生成したものではなくて本当に人間のエキスパート、例えば CSS の Rachel Andrew さん [TODO: 名前確認] っていう方がいるんですけど、すごい CSS 界隈で有名な人なんですけど、その人が書いたスキルとか、Google Chrome エンジニアリングチームの人たちが書いたスキルとかもあったりしてて、これは正直エージェントだけでなくて人間が読んでも良さそうなドキュメントいっぱい入ってそうだなと思います。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
中身少し見たんですけど、使い方というか仕様だけではなくてベストプラクティスみたいなことも多く書いてあったので、それが反映できるっていうのはすごいありがたいスキルかなと。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
個人的な意見なんですけど、最近こういったスキルの開発とか、モデルにどうやって効率よく新しいものを教えるかについて調べたりしてるんですけど、この Modern Web Guidance の設計も結構面白い設計になっていて、単純に Markdown をスキル配下に置くのではなくて、1 回 Web 検索に関連するスキルを入れた上で、そのための埋め込みを生成して、RAG という方法なんですけど、直接参照させるではなくて、一回ベクトル検索でセマンティック、意味で近い意味で一致するスキルだけを引っ張ってきて、それでエージェントのコンテクストを無駄に汚さないっていうメリットがあるので、内部で RAG を使ったスキルになっているのが非常に面白いなと思ってました。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
膨大なドキュメントがあるので、単純にどこを読みに行くかっていう指示ではなくて、RAG を前段に入れてやっているっていうところはすごい面白いです。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Agent に関する発表がもう 1 つあったんですけど、前から Chrome DevTools MCP があったと思いますが、今回の I/O で Chrome DevTools for Agents というのが発表されたんですけど、これは名前が変わっただけではあるんですけど、Chrome の DevTools って皆さん開発でよく使うと思うんですが、これをエージェントから利用できるというものになっています。これをエージェントから利用するとどういうメリットがあるかというと、普段 DevTools で見ているようなパフォーマンスパネルだったり、エレメントの一覧のパネルだったり、コンソールログだったり、そういった開発者しか見ない情報がエージェントのソースとして得ることができるので、アウトプットを大幅に高品質化できるということがあります。いろいろな事例が紹介されていたので、例えばサイバーエージェントさんでは Web UI を Chrome DevTools for Agents で分析させて、例えば何かエラーであったりとか、アクセシビリティ的に良くない実装がされていたときに、そこからのフィードバックをもとに自動修正するといったようなことが簡単にできるようになるというような事例を出していました。
それがエージェントを使って開発するための新しい発表だったんですけど、実際にブラウザに Web プラットフォームに入る新しい API についてもいろいろと発表とかセッションがあったりしたんですけど、去年も実はこれについて話してたんですけど、Built-in AI というブラウザでオンデバイスのモデルが使えるような API がようやく Chrome でリリースされたので、Chrome でステーブルになって 48 ですね、Firefox と Safari がちょっとまだなんですけど、ブラウザで結構気軽に小さいモデルを利用できるような API なんですけど、実は私たちもこの Built-in AI を使ったサンプルをいくつか作っていまして、今回 I/O でもサンプルとして載せていただいたんですが、Yahoo! 知恵袋というサービスのランキングの品質を高める内部的な管理ツールがあるんですけど、そこの中で実は Built-in AI を活用しています。Built-in AI はやはりオンデバイスのモデルなので、少しモデルが小さくて品質がなかなか出ないというところがあるんですけど、私たちの実験の中では AI が弾いた少しちょっと良くないコメントだったりとかと、人間が弾いたコメントが割と一致していて、ほぼ 100% カバーできるような品質は保てていました。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
この API を使うと、なんでサーバーサイドのもっと性能のあるモデルを使わないかという話も出てくると思います。いくつかのメリットがあるんですよね、この Built-in AI を使うこと。1 個目のメリットは、もちろんネットワークバウンダリを超えないから、ユーザーのデータがユーザーのデバイスを一切出ないというプライバシーが守られるというメリットですね。2 つ目はコストだと思います。オンデバイスで動くのでサービス提供側は一切コストがかからないですね。もしかしたら AI の開発をされている方は悩んでいるかもしれないですが、トークン単位でお金がかかります。これは結構ユーザーのリクエストごとに課金がされるとバカにならない費用が発生すると思うんですが、これは一切かからないというところで、かなり今後の AI の活用にキーを握る技術なんじゃないかなと個人的には思っています。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
そうですね。今のところは Chrome がそのための専用モデルをダウンロードしていて、実は今のところはデスクトップの Chrome でしかダウンロードされないんですけど、今後だったらもしかしたら Android とかでも動いたり、あとは Chrome がダウンロードするモデルではなくて、OS にもともと内蔵しているモデルとかを使うようになる可能性もあるので、そうなったらユーザーの負担も減って、毎回大きいモデルをダウンロードしないといけないといった負担がなくなるので、それは便利そうなんですけど。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
実はこの API に関しては Firefox と Safari が反対意見を取っていて、Web の仕様にしたくないという意見を取っていますね。元 Chrome チームで Firefox チームにいる Jake Archibald さんが、実は Google I/O の数日前に Bluesky で反対意見を公開する動画を作ったんですけど、それも今回の I/O でかなり話題になっていました。Firefox がやっぱり心配していることは、モデルを Apple でも作るほどのリソースを持たないブラウザ vendor がどうしたらいいかとか、これでより Google の力が強まるんじゃないかなとか、そういう心配のところがやっぱりあったので、実は 2 年前とか出た当初からこういった批判の声はあったんですけど、今回よりそれが表面化してきているっていうのが実情なのかなと思って。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
実際にやっぱり使ってみると本当に簡単に使えますし便利ではあるんですが、モデルとしてやはり Google の作ったモデルで動作していることには変わりないので、これがどれだけ普及するかによっては、おそらく確かにブラウザのシェアとか他にも関わってくるようなところなので、Firefox はかなり気を使う部分なんじゃないかなとは思っています。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
あと、そういう反対意見があったのに Google さんが I/O のイベントに向けて API を無理やり通したみたいな批判もあったんですけど、それも確かにいくつかのブラウザが一緒に決める Web の仕様なのに、こういう進め方にはちょっと問題があったんじゃないかなと。
これはちょっと AI 関連の炎上するブラウザ API だったんですけど、期待される API も 1 個あって、それが WebMCP っていう Microsoft と Google が合同開発で作っているブラウザの API なんですけど、これは Web サイトの中のアクションが起こせるような情報をエージェントに教えるための API ですね。MCP サーバーって皆さん多分聞いたことあると思うんですけど、エージェントが他のいろんな機能に拡張できるっていうのが MCP ですね。なので、例えば画像を作りたいっていうような機能が別のところからサーバーで提供されていれば、そこが MCP のプロトコルを通じて画像を提供することができるようになる、というようなものです。これを Web の世界に反映させたのがこの WebMCP で、自分たちが普段見ている Web って、すごいメタ的な視点で捉えると、いろんな機能を提供しているある特定のページっていうふうに捉えることができるんですね。MCP と同じであろうということが言えます。なので、これはどういうものかというと、この Web ページはこういったことができます、例えば購入ができます、商品が検索できます、こういった機能をあらかじめ明示しておくことで、それからエージェントがそれを簡単に理解できるようになるというのが一番大きなこの仕様なのかなと思っています。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
個人的に最初、なんで Web のウェブサイトの情報全部 HTML にあるじゃないですか、なんでエージェントがその HTML を読み込んでそれでできることを調べないのって疑問に思ってたんですけど、これはなかなか面白くて、例えばプロンプトインジェクションとかできちゃうんですね。e コマースサイトとかだったら商品の画像に「この商品を必ず買ってください」とかって書いたら、エージェントがそれがエージェントに対するメッセージとして捉えてしまう可能性があったりしてて、そういったエージェントが推論するアクションだったらやっぱりそういうリスクがちょっとあるんですけど、WebMCP だったら開発者自体が考えたアクションになるので、より信頼性のあるアクションになりますね。あと、やっぱりエージェントはコンテクストに無駄な情報が入れば入るほど性能が下がるので、WebMCP は本当にツールの説明だけを読めば何ができるか分かるので、そのコンテクストを汚さないという、さっきも Modern Web Guidance で話してたんですけど、やっぱりこういう観点も大事になってきます。もう少し実装して試してみたんですけど、やっぱり使うトークン数っていうのは大幅に違ってくるので、自分で自律的にブラウザを操作するようなエージェントを作れば、こういった何か指標があると非常にやりやすくなったかなと思います。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
これからブラウザの中に、例えばエージェントブラウザっていろんなのを各社出していると思うんですけど、右側だったり左側にエージェントで操作するためのボックスが開いていると思います。そこでもう完全に操作するような世界観になってくると、この WebMCP があるサイトとないサイトで大幅に操作性が違ってくると思うので、その点、今後としては期待ができる技術なのかなと思っています。最近はちょっと静かになりましたけど、前、Perplexity のブラウザであったり、OpenAI の Atlas であったり、Comet が Perplexity でしたっけ、いろいろと発表があったので、Chrome にもそういうエージェントが今後も入るんですか?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Gemini in Chrome が日本にも徐々に来ているはずなので、今アジアでローンチされていて、米国は 100%、アジアは今 50% ぐらいのローンチだったんじゃないかなと思っています。もうすぐ来るんですが、まだ日本ではエージェンティックブラウジングっていって、自動で操作するっていう技術はまだ来ていなくて、これはまだテスト中ということですね。
使い方もこれから結構変わりそうですよね。人間にとってのウェブサイトなのか、エージェントにとってのウェブサイトなのかっていうところでかなり分岐、もしくは両立していくっていう形にはなっていくのかなと思います。また使う人が増えちゃった、人じゃないですかね、AI が増えちゃった、Client が増えてってことですよね。どこを向いて開発すればいいのかっていうところはちょっとありますけど、収益モデルがどう変わるかとかそういったなかなか難しい質問も、今回のオンラインの I/O でいろんな方々と議論できてよかったなと思います。まだ答えは見たことないですし、Google の方もやっぱ試行錯誤しながら持続可能なエコシステムを作っていくってところがやっぱりメッセージとしてありましたね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
続いては、AI とそれもなんか AI 関連ない API もあったことは結構個人的に嬉しかったですね。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku
ここ最近どのニュースでも AI と関連する、飽きる時もあるので。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
今回結構ワクワクする AI と全く関係ない API もあったのでよかったなと思いました。その新しい API の 1 個目が HTML in Canvas という API なんですけど、キャンバスが HTML 要素のその中に何でも書けるっていう要素になってます。例えば three.js とかそういった 3D の何かが描画できるツールであったり、WebGPU とかを使ってレンダーしたグラフィックを、結構面白い体験がいろいろと作れる API になります。ただ、結構大事な欠点があって、それはアクセシビリティが今まで結構問題になっていたというところですね。なぜかというと、キャンバスの中に何かを連打したとしても、それが DOM の一部ではないので、ブラウザが提供するアクセシビリティツールで利用することができなくて、障害のある方にとっては多分利用することができない結構難しかったので、多くのユースケースだとちょっと非アクセシブルなユースケースになってたところが多いんですけど、今回は HTML in Canvas っていう新しいキャンバスの中で HTML が書けて、それが DOM の一部の新しい機能がブラウザに増えて、これを使った結構面白いウェブサイトが出てくるんじゃないかなと思いました。HTML を 2D に変換して、そこでいろんな画像処理をかけられる、本当に面白い表現がたくさんできるんですよね。普段だったら HTML でしか書けなかった表現の上に、さらにエフェクトをかけたりであると。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
デモだと水滴が垂れてくるようなインプットボックスが表示されていたりとか、多分これまでなかったリッチな表現というのができるようになるのかなと思って、私も面白く見てました。かなりリッチで面白い体験がいろいろ今後増えそうですよね。例えばデベロッパーキーノートにあった、車を買うときに車のオプションがプレビューできるようなのがあって、3D の中にディスプレイがあって、ディスプレイの中にあるインプット要素とかが普通の Web の要素として利用できてすごい面白いなと思いました。インタラクティブの中に現実があるみたいな少し不思議な体験がすごく簡単に作れるようになったと言えるかなと思います。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku
もう一つのちょっとワクワクする API なんですけど、これなんていうんですかね、Declarative Partial Updates、日本語にすると。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
日本語にすると「宣言的部分更新」。これはサーバーサイドレンダリングで一部を除いてレンダリングして、後から宣言的に欠けた部分を埋められるような API ですか?
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
そうですね。これはこの中に出てきたものだとかなり低レイヤーな部分かなと思うんですけど、今レンダリングするための方式ってすごいたくさんあると思います。例えば、もう全てを読み込んできてハイドレーションといって、読み込んできた中にデータをバインディングする方法であるとか、ただそれだとコストが高いのでコンポーネントごとにバインディングする方法だとかいろいろあるんですけど、これはよく言われているような Islands Architecture と言われているような部分的に HTML を更新してくれるような、これまでライブラリがやってきたような技術を Web 標準でやってしまおうっていうすごい面白い試みになっています。今の標準だとストリーミングで HTML の次の更新を送れるようになっているので、それを組み合わせると、ストリームで送られてきた情報をここに書き込めば良いっていうのを一応宣言的に HTML の中に組み込めると。専用のスタートとかエンドとか少しちょっとトリッキーなタグを使ってどこにデータを流し込むかっていうのを宣言するんですけど、逆に言うとこれを使えばこれまで他のライブラリが行ってきた、少し JavaScript がないと実現できないような部分が、更新の処理を Web 標準に流し込むことができるので、大幅に JavaScript の量を減らせるんじゃないかなと個人的には思っています。もしかすると Astro であったりとか htmx とか、少しそういう静的な更新によっているライブラリにかなり朗報になるんじゃないかなと思っていて、より簡単にそういった部分更新のアーキテクチャが反映できるので、パフォーマンス界隈の人はみんなちょっと注目しているという感じですかね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
HTML にあらかじめ穴を開けて、サーバーからデータの準備ができたらこの穴に埋めてみたいなことが宣言的に利用できるような。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
そうですね、Hotwire や Islands Architecture とかにかなり似ている技術かなと思います。JavaScript を減らしてユーザーにより丈夫で高速にロードできる体験が提供できるというのが API のメリットですね。もしかしたら一般の人たち、ライブラリを使う人たちはあまり関係しない、どちらかというとライブラリの中の人というか、かなり低レイヤーなところになるので目に触れる機会は少ないかもしれないですが、すごい面白いかなと思いました。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku
ちょっと PHP を思い出したので、そうだなって思いました。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
僕らは長年の経験からすればそうだなって思いました。そういうと少し苦手意識があり…。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
それ以外なんか今回の I/O の感想とか、これ良かったなとかそういうのって触れたいところありますか?
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
そうですね、自分は Antigravity が今回かなり開発統合環境として推しているなっていう印象があって、I/O の中で面白かったのは、Antigravity Coffee Co. でしたっけ、Antigravity が主催したコーヒーカフェっていうのが一応大きなブースとしてセットされていて、そこでは生成 AI で生成された画像を、あれはココアなんですかね、ココアかなと思いますね、カプチーノの上にココアを使ってプリンティングしてくれる、生成 AI で生成した自分の好きな場所っていうところをプリンティングしてくれるようなカフェがあって、それはすごく推しているなっていう証拠でもあるし、実際にコーヒーも美味しかったですね。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku
楽しかったですし、あと結構可愛い家とかを生成して、それをコーヒーに印刷できたので、気軽な面白い経験だったなと思います。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Google の担当の人が「このコーヒーマシンはすごい高いんだ」って、すごいですね。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku
印刷するマシンですね、それは高いよね。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
自分は Google Beam が面白かったなと思っていて、オンラインの会議システムで 3D で相手の表情が見えたりとか、より立体的にプレゼンテーションができたりとか、斜めから見てもちゃんと立体感ある表現ができるというところで、去年も I/O で Beam のデモがあったのかな、私は初めて見たんですけど、オンラインの会議とかがやる中でよりリッチな表現がデバイスレイヤーでできるっていうのも非常に Google の取り組みの幅広さを表してるなというふうに思います。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Beam は実は 2 年前からあるんですけど、やっぱり見た人見た人みんなすごいって言っているのに、まだあんまり大手に出てきてなかったりするのかな。多分去年から買えるようになったんですね、別に導入することはできるんですけど、導入してる会社がまだ少なそうだな、高いのか、台が高いのかもしれないですね。
個人的な感想、今年の感想なんですけど。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku
日本人がすごい多いなって思いました。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I/O がアメリカのカリフォルニアで開催されるのに、なんかまあまあの人数の日本人来てるなって思いました。自分も理由は全然分かんないですけど、今回でもやっぱりそのデモの中でも結構パートナー企業と連携して紹介されるという事例がかなり日本の企業が多かったんじゃないかなと思っています。やっぱりメリットがある技術が多かったというところもあるし、国柄もあるんですかね、そういうのを実験的にやりたいという人がかなりの日本企業がそこに参加しながら自分たちの体験を模索していたっていうのがあって、それを実際にやった人が多かったのかもしれないですね。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku
会場を歩くとファッションで「この人絶対日本人だ」って思ったら、実際に近づいたら日本語で喋ってますねってなってました。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Google のエンジニアとかと喋って面白いなと思ったのが、最近アメリカのトレンドかどうかはちょっと分からないんですけど、音声入力がすごい流行っていて、みんながコーディングエージェントと音声入力を使って話してるんで、コーディングエージェントとメッセンジャーアプリを開いて、そこにババッといっぱいやってほしいことを投げて、AI がその音声入力、つまずいたり言いたいことがうまくまとまらなくても、AI がそれをいい感じの文章にしてくれるので、最終的にすごい効率良いプロンプティング方法になるから。日本でも流行るんですかね、日本でも多分今結構一部では使い始めてるんじゃないかなと思っていて、アプリもすごい使いやすいのが、何気なく話し始めても AI がすごい強力に補正をしてくれるんですよ、なので手で入力するより圧倒的に早い、書き直したり手で打つより早く感じてしまうので、今は多分声で入力している人は日本でも少しいるっていうのと、これから増えてくるんじゃないかなと個人的にも思う。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
会場にも電話ボックスの形をしたブースがいくつも並んでいるエリアがあって、そこはディスプレイがついた電話機みたいなのがあったんですけど、そこでどういうアプリを作りたいかっていうのを対話していくと、最後に QR コードが出てモバイル直前のコードが吐き出されているっていう、そういう体験もあったので、エポンゼっていうのは、これからのトレンドとしてあるのかなというふうに思います。MIT がなんと Gemini、Gemini ですよね、Gemini と話すとアプリができるっていうような体験でしたね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Google の一人のエンジニアからの感想は、やっぱこれ流行ってからオフィス環境がすごいうるさくなったっていう文句があったので、みんながやっぱり大きい声は出さなくて、なんかつぶやきでみんながエージェントと話してるらしくて、それですごいハイピッチなノイズがオフィス環境で広まってるらしいです。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku
囁き声みたいないろんなところから聞こえてもう余計に集中できなくなるっていう、それちょっとあるあるある。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
というわけで、今回は浜田さんと喜楽さんとともに Google I/O を 2026 年から報告してきました。LINE ヤフーのフロントエンドコミュニティ UIT ではこのようなフロントエンドに関わる議論や意見交換を日々行っています。過去のエピソードでは社内勉強会などから発生したものも多くありますので、今後も積極的に情報を発信していきたいと思います。また、このポッドキャストに関するご意見・ご感想があれば、ハッシュタグ #UIT_INSIDE にてつぶやいていただけるとスタッフで確認いたします。ありがとうございました。
NOTE Speaker: mahamada
ありがとうございました。
NOTE Speaker: tkiraku